I'm playing gigolo there's money dance
loving you romance ooh what to say yeah
there will come a day when you throw
pass away the room what would they say
about me when the end comes on no I was
just a gigolo life goes on without me so
ah got no ba day nobody cares for me
no body sing it be no nobody nobody want
some sweet mama come take a chance with
me cuz I ain't so bad
headed Li this show is presented by on
it this show the Churchill what's
happening now is brought to you by me
undies me undies sends you your favorite
underwear for the price of two cocktails
for a limited time our audience the
listeners of the church so what's
happening now gets 20% off of your first
order
when you go to me undies calm / Joey
that's me undies calm / Joey the show is
also brought to you by blue apron I just
cooked my favorite Lupin meal with them
ever last week it's a peanut it's a West
African peanut chicken with blue apron
you can cook all of the meals you wanna
make all the meals you're making at
restaurants for less than $10 per
delicious meal go to blue apron comm /
Joey right now check out this week's
menu and get your first 3 meals for free
with Free Shipping and blue apron calm /
you
Monday February 6 the day the devil was
buried at [__] sea and hit the head
the Church of what's happened now
you
what's happened you bad [__]
welcome the podcast Ville whatever the
[__] Joey Diaz my main man Lisa at being
Delray for another fun-filled few hours
of drug-induced [__] music talk
I'm your host flavor great weekend in
Nashville if he came to the shows thank
you very much
if you want to seen Dean Del Ray for his
birthday shows and La Jolla thank you
very much
comedies of all-time high but it
wouldn't be this high without you [__]
people coming to the shows and putting
these [__] performances together I
mean it's just comedy every comedy club
honor I talked to says his weekends are
crazy now whether there's a monkey up
there or [__] Marc Maron's there or
Joe Rogan I mean these places are packed
and it's like a comedy [__]
revolution all over again you heard
about this from the early 90s by the
time I got into comedy they said it was
dead what I see now is a [__] comedy
revolution
I see Lee sweat and going through
changes already alright am going and
deep sweating sweating from what who
knows from it it seems like we took a
sugar cube but uh do you think like when
do you have you talked to comedy club
owners for comedians who don't have
podcasts like it do they see a dip for
with people who come in don't have this
scene Brian Morton at the Laugh Factory
in [__] Chicago sells out every
Saturday night ok and maybe let's say he
puts 10 people at maybe for those people
are podcasting Wow
ok but it's not like podcasters like Joe
Rogan know mark or something like that
these are economies just people involved
in calming it yeah but you don't need it
doesn't need to be at mark or Joe
Rogan's level especially like if you
guys had started podcast when you were
open my course you'd have people there
might be one person but you'd have at
least one person from that podcast on
this PI plus now that's true too that's
a good way of looking at it what's up
with you Dean there is e man that
[__] we've wiped me out
that's the Teva [__] killed you I
don't even get sativas it's 24-karat man
yeah well I told you we're [__]
around tonight
we're taking this a deep murky murky
waters of the [__] drug on the world
[__] vice and that [__] this is
living it you see [__] living
in it will mix and edibles
we took liquid CID with the Ice Cube
we're taking it back here we've got no
time to [__] around I'm not even sure
was in that chocolate bar who knows who
cares I don't care I find some in my
pocket now I take it why it's too
[__] short who gives a [__] you got
six hours to kill and you find something
in your pocket you go for broke that's
it
you okay nervous at all no I've been
through that already in fact what's a
what's a [__] powder or something
gonna do to me I don't when I was a kid
I used to do that
those that THC crystals [__] that
[__] that [__] angel that angel
with these to call that Dean Thorazine
angel gasps angel dust [__] but they
gave it different names like I get
scared for like eight minutes like I'd
make-believe I didn't know what I may
believe I got make-believe like I didn't
know what I was doing or something and I
get [__] hammered man Dean you okay
yeah man you need some water you need
some air yeah we even give dealer elbow
we didn't need to give him a star just
listen Eva what's it making you feel
just [__] good good sit back relax sit
back and put some music on you're the
captain of your own enterprise word up
[__] but no Nashville was great
the food was great yeah you said you had
national hot chicken and it wasn't it
wasn't your yeah it went right [__]
through me oh no it's not like spicy
chicken like with wings like hot ones
this is chicken with intense pepper on
it I had the mildly and I took two bites
of it and it sprinkled on the skin the
skin and it white meat is the white meat
the skin is [__] done Oh No and I ate
it and I had to go to the bathroom
within ten seconds like it went down my
esophagus into my stomach and whatever I
had in my stomach it just went right
through was like Drano I had a run to
the bathroom at this place it was
disgusting and
again when I got the hotel I've never
done that before like I had the first
time for in my whole life this weekend I
had diarrhea like I didn't feel good
like I went [__] like eight times is we
I don't know what I ate god knows what
you know see here's the thing whenever I
post food now people in fact I could
post food at like Morton's the
ritz-carlton and they're gonna say it's
lizard means yeah but you don't do it on
those places you keep going back to
lizard me places that's why they know a
lesson what did you eat before the
diarrhea I don't remember uh turkey club
that was it yeah from where oh you don't
even want to know
[__] Barney's Beanery in Burbank I
was trying to get something quick oh
yeah that was tear that was a bad idea
that was it but you know what I saw this
weekend that was actually not bad a
dog's purpose
it's a stupid like it's a stupid movie
it's one of these movies that they're
doing now that doesn't really have a
story but it was just nice like it was
nice for anyone who had a in a pet as a
kid they think I thought they did a good
job I don't know maybe I'm gonna see
movies that eight-year-olds go to but
what would you go see this Burbank I
don't know and you don't you don't want
to go see that movie go see what the dog
does like I said I don't know what's
happened to you though
well it took me four years to create you
blew it in one [__] month from a
dog's life to Barney's Beanery for a
[__] turkey club it's like one
disaster after another with you is
what's wrong with the turkey club
nothing Bonnie's [__] Beanery I
didn't want to burn her I'm sorry I show
you guys there's a thousand things in
that Molly's there was nothing open like
we tried to go to BJ's that had a line
out the door we tried to go to islands
that had a line out the door so we try
we tried but it just shoot yourself next
time cuz that's the luck you have to
shoot you so it's never gonna get better
it's the only getting worse on a daily
basis I have a good time on a turkey
club in the dog's life unbelievable you
say I gotta deal with Dean Delray yeah
Dean dal-rae is [__] up jack one
little hit I know this sativa was strong
I know is that you hearing things right
like those out like a buzz I got so high
this [__] afternoon X of T but I
heard buzzes like I thought I kept
reading a car engine [__] you know
whatever smoke some more that's what we
need to do this is body [__] I love
that when John sees someone going
through like train the deepest changes
that anyone's ever gone through Binks
you like GLS you're like I gotta get I
gotta get my [__] together how come I'm
not going through those changes man this
is gonna be the night of the change it's
gonna be the title of their podcast
night of the changes oh my god yeah this
is he was [__] good that [__] the
[__] that's a it's a hammer well
speaking of uh well I have any coherency
it was weird it's weird to me last night
watching the Super Bowl because these
are the players that I really fell in
love with when I was in high school and
middle school like I think Tom Brady was
in Oh seven or something that's when I
started high school was oh seven like
what was it like for you guys seeing all
these musicians getting older
does it [__] with you at all I guess I
don't really retire like athletes do
yeah we could Joe Montana man I watched
him so we get old break away a king yeah
ya know they definitely start I mean I
haven't seen uh you see some people fall
too quickly with sports but Tom Brady is
still kicking in but it's uh I know it's
weird it's weird growing older I like
the under the game [__] had me all
[__] up last week cuz I like knowing
but I know the NFC has you don't get to
the Super Bowl represent the NFC if you
don't have an outstanding [__]
strength compared to an AFC team ya know
I could see you somebody folding because
it was 60 points the over and under and
the under came all the way into the
fight you'd only if they would have
scored a field golden one the under
still with a camera because it was fifty
nine and a half
that just just goes to show you that
they have it down to a science
with football bookmaking okay oh it's
scary over there I just wanted to put a
huh miles on the game on the total the
other just to watch the [__] game in
a million years I Love New England in
the over that was the obvious pick that
was the obvious pick that that was it
right there was no England and Tom
Brady's gonna put up fifty five [__]
points by himself I did not see it like
that
yesterday changed my world you know I'm
reading a book called I totally we're
gonna preview it one day this month the
war of art you know and but the
distractions that we have as human
beings and whatnot if you looked whether
you were a football fan or not if you
have a minute look at the last three
minutes of that game and watch that
man's face they were down twenty eight
to three and one in eight to three only
only yes he still has a chance to goalie
I don't know yeah you're making fun of
me he's not looking good and he's not
looking good and then and it shocked me
because this guy I've known him to be a
tank a white tank he's that he's the
strongest white guy that's ever walked
this [__] planet hands down him in
the Allman Brothers hands down when he
you know to look on his face and it just
goes to prove what I always talk about
in the show man when you want something
really bad it's there
it ain't gonna just pop up [__]
mysteriously but if you work for [__]
it's there all those things that you put
in those practice things that you do
that you think don't really matter
you all saw last night and his
performance he was what's called
unconscious it happens with comedy it
happens with music it happens with
sports and happens to a lot of things
when you're putting the left the best
performance of your life on and you
really are unconscious you don't even
know what you're doing you're depending
or you're not depending on anything
you're just doing what you've done for
the last twenty years the best of its
Ben that's how you have to look at that
situation I looked at a great game last
night I mean I woke up and it was a
minute left in the second quarter I was
in shock but I wasn't surprised but all
I have to say is what I got from that
game yesterday was if you watch [__]
Tom Brady those last three minutes watch
his face and he's got psyched and they
were getting to him and they were
turning him around
it didn't matter he didn't give up he
knew he was winning he knew like he knew
watch the lat it was on again last night
and I watched it late night last night I
watched the last [__] quarter last
night till 1:00 in the morning and
that's what I was watching that that's
what we strive to be that's why they
tell you the practice that's why they
tell you that do the same [__] over
again he didn't throw a 90-yard bomb he
didn't [__] throw any yard boy he
just did what he's been doing all his
life 10 yard 12 yard darts zip and those
receivers you gotta take your hands off
their heads do your hats off to them all
of them
the do orlando julius from the other
[__] team made a catch oh yeah I mean
they would just you know I don't look at
it but if you're [__] shallow and
ignorant and you could say that Atlanta
choked no they didn't they play the
great game they were there all the way
to the end they just got I played by the
[__] best in the game there's no
shame in that they played a great season
they played a great game they had them
up against the [__] ropes they just
played against the [__] best there is
yeah ever as a coach and as a [__]
football player I mean they they went up
against the [__] goods so for you
[__] the giggling tonight
talking about our lanta choked and
whatever Helena didn't choke man watch
that game that number 97 that defensive
tackle oh yeah he's an Beast he's a
beast they didn't show what they did was
got outplayed and that's how you have to
look at that you know that's it
New England my [__] congratulations I
wish I'd go to your parade tomorrow cuz
I'd run up and hug [__] Tom Brady
me too but I don't have the goods or the
means I got [__] to do on people to see
them all maybe someday when me and
Richard millionaires or mainly if
[__] rich and famous we go again to
see Tom Brady's son throw [__] five
touchdowns in a game with some [__] now
I made fun of it and it's easy to make
fun of but the Lady Gaga halftime show
yeah watch it I turned it off I watched
the UFC Conda and I don't watch football
to see people dance and say that and I
made the comment like it's not at all
the NFL's fans but just watching it last
night she did a good job like she just
I've never seen a musician before one
between like six songs and like take no
breaks and the costume changes so it
wasn't at all what I think the Super
Bowl halftime show would be in
apparently because maybe I just don't
watch the halftime show up Halliday
Beyonce and everything in years past so
apparently that's what it's for but just
seeing her like that's what I try to
look at when I when I'm watching
something now that I don't like I don't
like I feel like I'm getting negative
too much like I want to at least try to
look for something positive in it so
just to see her right and in people's
all over the Internet today were saying
that she killed it all her fans were
saying she killed it so it's uh it's
just cool seeing someone just doing that
I'm like the biggest stage ever I just
didn't I don't like that [__] during
halftime it drives me crazy you know
like I watched it one year I forget who
was Paul McCarthy sang myself
eight songs yeah that's a few years ago
this is something you know it's just I
just want to see a [__] football game
I'm sorry
you might think I'm [__] with autism
I just want to see a [__] football
game and maintain the mood I got invited
to 20 things I don't want to be around
20 people when I'm watching I [__]
Superboy I just want to watch the game
and relax how I watch any other [__]
I don't know why I've always been like
that I think I want the one Super Bowl
party I saw a dip and I'm like this
ain't for me yeah I think I went to a
couple years ago me and my wife had just
moved to the valley
my lady invited us to an Oscar party it
was the worst it was the worst thing I
have a bit of violets an Oscar I'm not
from that school of thought man I've
never really been from that school like
the night like that the most shameful
thing I heard was the night of the
election people haven't liked victory
parties already playing for Hillary
Clinton people buying new suits and new
clothes and [__] that's not all
elections [__] about man but see
that's what it was this year you know
that's why I wasn't in the state of
shock that we are now but I've never
really been like a a fake party type guy
I want to go to a party you see the
devil I don't know the party Domingo and
the crackers I hate that [__] with wives
I [__] that [__] drives me crazy it
always has he always has been I had the
best day ever yesterday it was a we were
supposed to go and actually spend it
with Vicki Pez and her husband but we
like it just got turned around and I
couldn't I I'm so happy it did Paula
made wings best wings I've had in LA
she's never made wings before that shows
you the shitty wings that I've been
having in LA
it was amazing she breaded the whole
thing it was great Frank's redhot with
butter that was delicious
she made mac and cheese homemade and
then she made it she baked cookies and I
was sitting my pajamas it was a perfect
day it was a it was one of those I
haven't had one of those in a while
where I woke up today I was like [__]
there's nothing I would have changed
about yesterday
you're a [__] bum but John's Josh I
gotta deal with those are you back to
Ground Zero yet yeah [__] that was
that [__] was like the claw just grab my
knees and just threw me do haven't dude
it was like hey I'm just like Oh bro
after jujitsu today Wow I smoked a few
bowls I went in the back I smoked two
bowls and I did around my business and I
was sitting there I go I am so [__]
stones in this [__] sativa
yeah that [__] [__] me up like do did
not think you smoked he said you wanted
hash I don't have no
I just got ashes man made unless I get
it from the one eyed you I don't [__]
with it no well I didn't I didn't ride
over I rode uber sounds like [__]
I'll get I'll get high tonight go with
the ride with you guys man that [__] was
just like it was it was like it grabbed
me and threw me down like hey you ain't
going nowhere
you know that's the type of reefer that
you smoked as a teenager yeah and that
really makes you appreciate music I
don't like that now say music I always
like going to concerts I loved all that
stuff but there's nothing better for me
than to get really stoned
I'm putting your phones on and blast
that music yeah and you know if you hear
a song you really like and you get in
till you put it on again you know you're
like [__] to put them on again Jesus
Christ that sounded good like are you
guys open with that Maiden oh and I was
out cold man
it was actually kind of scary for me it
was like rats [__] bass that bass ah
Steve Harrigan killings [__] savagery
nice time you hear that you're like what
the [__] is that one other guitars come
in yeah yeah well that help came out
maybe one that wasn't the type of music
I listen to like my forest out was like
Black Sabbath right example and you know
maybe deep purple if I was in the mood
but when I first heard that I was like
there's something about that [__] that I
still listen to that out mhm I'll put
the whole out mom and do [__] in the
room and you know and move around
I mean Maiden with Bruce Dickerson has
never really grabbed me yeah can I lie
to you I have 666 the number of the
beast and run to the hills and all that
stuff I know they have a plane now and
they have great numbers yeah that they
just never really been for me I do not
know why yeah I love that [__] number
the beasts record man that that song 22
acacia Avenue also get soft good job
right that was good
I like I just never really bought into
the whole thing I got what
I were doing by the time they started
coming out with 666 the number of the
beast I had already seen the devil you
not impressing me [__] you make
you bet you want to impress me well get
the devil boss ha ha yeah the time they
came out with number 666 the number of
the beast what year was that I don't
know man run for the hills is 83 oh oh
yeah that's it 83 cuz I saw him a day on
the green with foreigner isn't that
crazy
I know it was heart they played with
heart like crazy i'ma tell you something
man people goof on Florida no I was a
couple jam the first time is me all the
way oh yeah I [__] love the first down
then a long long way though oh that's
great there's a couple jams feels like
the first time is that on there feels
like the first times on there too they
opened up for the stones yeah one year
and there's 78 maybe they open the first
door right I mean my knee I don't know
one of those [__] years and I'll tell
you I you wanted not to like them you
thought they were a little on the pop
side yeah but they're pretty [__]
good oh come on talk to you about some
before I forget that we were watching
before this to explain the people you
know I was there with my own eyes when I
saw the van Halen at the garden destroy
that guitar and Black Sabbath how to try
to follow yeah I think he is laying I
saw van Halen again by that time I had
grown a hatred towards not a hatred but
this light too after women and children
first for some reason yeah I didn't like
David Lee Roth no more yeah he had worn
me out that poster yeah oh that wasn't
getting changed though Oh women each
other yeah yeah
but they won me over with an 81 with
fair warning fair warning I just
destroyed my insides of a wall crusher
and then I don't know what they put on
after fiber down IRA down which was
batted down yeah yeah that was man down
man hell yeah and then I thought that
was an 84 the big one 84 okay diver down
was 84 yeah and then I fade before they
broke up yep that was the Sammy comes in
now the I still remember being at the
Crestwood Hotel in Snowmass Village yeah
and sitting in employee housing I was 21
and there was a couple other people in
the room that were 20 at 21 but there
was this guy that was 27 that was like
trying to be cool you know I'm saying
like 28 trying to hit on 21 year old
girls and I got thrown arguing with him
that night I still remember this is
clear his dad but he was one of those
guys like we were watching something was
smoking pot and he came in like what a
case of beer to be cool yeah he's like I
can't wait for Hagar and I'll go and ban
Hagar they get together oh and like two
of us looked at him I shut the [__] up
he gives a [__] old man like get the
[__] out it he was trying to hit on one
of the girls look I'm I'm going I'm not
even excited about that yeah like I'm
more excited about the coke that's
coming getting delivered over here in
ten minutes I don't give a [__] about
man hey god yeah yeah yeah yeah right I
was so into that Edom and smile record I
brought the Spanish one tonight now that
was just first yep without van Halen
yeah
what's on their stop like Yankee rose
it's got that shy boy you know at that
time Steve Eve I was playing yeah he had
a great [__] back oh great great bad
killer and it was so really maybe two
years after David odd David Lee Roth
left and I guess by that time they had
put on two albums yeah that me hang on
man
people were begging for that for David
Lee Roth they'd come back and I got to
be honest here how is one of them yeah
you know I saw Sammy Hagar in the worst
position
I saw Sammy you ever hear when people
say to you when'd you start oh I started
comedy in Milwaukee really do you go
back to anymore now you know how it is
where you start that's where people
always remember you okay I went to like
that for concert bill one time like a
for Bill cuts
it was Black Sabbath with do wow I don't
remember who went on before that but
before that it was Sammy Hagar was
shakin Street oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah and opening the show yeah was who
was Sammy Hagar's ex-partner Montrose
Ronnie Montrose yeah this is bad
Wow so was Ronnie Montrose Sammy Hagar
shaking Street somebody else opened up
the Sabbath I don't remember who was and
then there was Sabbath in Philadelphia
at the spectrum Wow my favorite places
of all time all four of those uh-huh but
the funny thing was that wall David Lee
Roth was on stage this is what I really
liked I had come to Philly a lot like I
was always in Philadelphia it always
seemed like I was in Philly Philly
Philly Philly and the more I went to
Philly I gotta be honest I liked it yeah
it was Jersey only with something else
to add into it and the one time I'll
head to Philly Sammy Hagar was up on
stage just dying I don't know what the
[__] he was singing in 1983 was it 83
would do and no it was 1980 would do and
Sabbath that tour
yeah 80 yeah 80 wait and think eight is
the first one and this 81 was Sabbath I
mean yeah look that up heaven and hell
they have an in-house work yeah well
whatever that was that's when I saw
Sammy Hagar and Ronnie
but then I saw Ronnie Montrose I can't
open up a CBC oh yeah later on
no maybe two or three years after that
maybe I don't know
with his band Gama at the Nassau
Coliseum man April 17th and 1980 yeah
sure they doubted that this is the first
time they ever had this this uh with do
with one each week a new Wikipedia no no
Dean King check without to make sure I'm
on checking out no no that's it that's
it no no but if you're on Wikipedia will
tell you that how come the opening bands
were on the tour [__] like that all
right let me check Wikipedia but they
were people were spitting on their
fingers they couldn't spit far enough at
Sammy Hagar Oh
something was spitting on their fingers
Oh flicking their fingers ah and the
spit was coming up on Sammy Hagar on
he's trying to dodge my spit flickers
spit flick oh my gosh that's how
disgusting I Spit was coming from every
[__] hang like this boy my god
Oh arias and it wasn't for a while there
yeah I know what some people at home
were thinking I know there's some
savages at home right now going Joey
whether you [__] it was Blue Oyster
Cult yeah
because boy stop slacking Bluto yeah
yeah which was great I didn't see it but
I thought it was a great concert yeah I
always like let me tell you some some
enchanted evening oh great
by Blue Oyster Cult kick out the jams
brothers and sisters out opens oh my
[__] god there's something in the
middle man is Godzilla yeah oh my
[__] god
guys you wanna listen to a good live
album the covers crazy super the reaper
which is the reaper going down oh my god
some enchanted evening yeah bye I stir
call boys to call dude what's up dawg
you're looking at me all bug-eye this
[__] what are you feeling Lee I just
feel really speedy right now yeah I'm
just glad I'm count refers to our - you
could do a couple [__] jumping jacks
we did you smoke any of that weed I did
everything else about that we don't
really try that out
man give them a little [__] lots of
it this will get you cross-eyed oh man
yeah you want to try it this is the sure
wine I want to cross that as it is slow
it up to the top peacefully over his
shin will make a special man that weight
is strong what kind is it it's called 24
karat from perennial 24 karat [__] 24
karat knock your ass out I was so stoned
a little while ago I couldn't even talk
I couldn't talk at all you know I was
just looking at least switching his
fingers back and forth a zero oh yeah
everyone thinks I'm having a panic
attack when I do this I'm switching the
cameras seniors having a panic attack
with tweet takes three hits of this
[__] Laurens doing here this is the
real deal tonight people Monday February
8th month of February 6th I'm sorry yeah
[__] around yes I'm enchanted
evenings good oh yeah then they had
another album after that
yeah they add the one with don't fear
the reaper on which was they got what do
they got it agents of fortune hold on me
luck man I'll tell you the good ones
okay but was Oyster Cult killer this
[__] reefer okay say this weed is
crazy
oh my god look he's got drool from his
beard look at him look at him he looks
like Sinbad the sailor
give me that [__] pipe ah I'm smoking
that all the way this Dean I can see
where you went oh my god all right it's
a long killer it lit my lungs on fire
okay here's the one Joey okay you got
fire or the unknown origin what you okay
that is what's a
eighty-one that's the good one that's a
good one you got good one you know what
it's got on it look it's got Vernon for
you whenever I'm burning I'm burning
from burning for you it's got that heavy
metal song remember
I love burning for you the guitars on
yeah [__] tremendous sick right this
is a great album
oh it's got their best song ever put
this song Lee veterans of psychic oh
yeah boys I'm calling you man that's the
song if you're not into boys the cult
you should take a [__] second
thickest I got into them by mistake I
used to buy coke from this dude Randy
merggle god rest his soul
and he used to play this out every night
we were jacked up to the [__] gills
ah circa 1981 I was a junior in high
school stand in his house for six in the
morning snorting I'd run home take a
shower here it is Mary this one it was
on that movie heavy mouth yep it's a
heavy metal
[Music]
you
killer dude that's got all about that
it's so good yeah I got it I gotta get
back into my [__] memory bolt vault
of music I'm missing a bunch of [__]
yeah
just lost over the years abstract [__] I
used to be into it yeah this to me used
to be like abstract metal I never saw
them I totally I've never saw them blue
boys to call I've I just saw the videos
yeah I've watched some footage on
YouTube but I love the music but to live
on they put out destroyed me some about
you know we get into this conversation
all the time because we're both students
to the seventies and the eighties
what the [__] are gonna take but who's
gonna do these my bands oh yeah I don't
want to see anybody live where anybody
live unless it's something that we grew
up with that knows how to do a [__]
live home yeah I mean Pearl Jam you know
yeah if I know some Garden is back yeah
yep Soundgarden they're back man and you
know there's some good live shows out
there right now like rival sons dude so
great I brought that record over Queens
of the Stone Age getting ready Stone Age
I get oh those guys kill their Armenians
no that's system of the down they kill
it yeah that bad crush it crush - oh I
saw him at the forum like last year it
was like the 100-year anniversary of the
Armenian Genocide and they did a big
tour 13 places it was unbelievable
yeah they were huge they were my I was
really into them in high school system I
went down so great dude I mean that that
aerial song you know you use eNOS guy
dododo do-do-do-do that tune is killer
oh my god what's the other baby it's not
system with a Down but the other guy in
part no Rage Against the Machine no
matter for that you said there's another
band Oh rival sir are those funding this
is a second band they're the ones that
want an anthony bourdain show Oh
Quincy the stones talk that great
they're doing a record right now a new
one I can't even wait last one was
incorrect
they're like to me like a kind of like a
Zeppelin was would be now you know like
they they're really intricate and cool
but bluesy acid II you know all over the
board
it's punk rock hell [__] my new
favorite band is hero jr. yeah um right
yeah but but no one of the other bands
to look out for oh man
let's see I'm loving this that one that
Gorge era I was done by hero jr. yeah
destroys me I forget the neighborhood
right now with the little girl singing
the song is [__] and she's like
lip-synching yeah that's a great [__]
that's like a world-class [__] Jam I
also like those people Rogen like the
girl honey honey
oh you know they're like yeah I like her
I think there's something there for when
you don't know you can't predict the
[__] yeah future I think there's just so
many bands now like so many I can't keep
up with the younger bands yeah yeah
doing me stuff yeah some stuff is
[__] phenomenal some stuff is so
[__] bad that's it
some stuff is so bad it's unlistenable
it's called anger on
with open arms and in between the
[__] guitars
[Applause]
Oh Katie
[Music]
sounds like a blue-black bro ish yeah
but [__] like with the black roses
something today
yeah that guitar plays a student of the
game
yeah listen to how raw is great great
riffs great richness banana to cut down
on you know there's crabs yeah that's
what you need a good riff man that grab
you
somebody there's people who send me
different music yeah and some music is
[__] phenomenal I just don't like if
they send me something I'll look them up
on YouTube and I'll look at some YouTube
stuff and if I get three songs or
there's a dynamite I'm like Jesus Christ
yeah yeah these guys are great I just
gotta figure out how to download and all
yeah yeah yeah so I forget about it yeah
don't forget about it that's all it is
it's yeah that'll like it I forget about
it I got a thousand things on my [__]
play yeah no yeah man I liked like 30
different bands last year and I had to
keep notes on them because they kept
going what was that one band called oh
yeah this band
oh yeah oh yeah that you know I gotta go
refined it and I'm used to little
whiskey and no I don't go to that unless
it's something I want to see like I saw
judo last week therefrom except balls to
the wall judo came and did a whole set
of except songs it was insane oh man
all that [__] fast I wasn't sharks then
I think it was 25 or something so worth
it
I couldn't believe how mental it was it
was like an old-school metal show they
had them the moves you know like okay we
on this part of the song we're gonna go
up here you know it was like well done
pseudo up there and his camo pants
you got your bubbles do the wow man
and you know that's knots that you go to
those places I'm gonna have to go with
you one night you gotta come out alright
a kid it's just fun for like an hour
yeah it'd go like a big show like the
best shows already I'm done with but I
want to go to some more shows to see the
smaller bands yeah yeah that I started
thinking about comedians I started
thinking about you won't see the good
comics I'm normally central you'll see
the economics they like like if you into
clam Lea you're not gonna see Bill
heck's the full spectrum that you
deserve to see by just watching Comedy
Central I'm not putting that I'm not
saying anything bad about Comedy Central
could you put say a putz a Lestat seeing
it same thing for like Netflix or
whoever you right now I'm just talking
about Comedy Central okay so I grew up
listening to PLJ right well then any W
great sources of whatever but this is
what I've been thinking at the age of 54
which I'll be next week they were biased
it buys like I am they're playing music
that they kind of like or they really
like you know some leaving the band the
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba but I don't think we're
hearing the best of them it's like today
when I'm driving down the street and I
hear rock and rolling noise pollution
that's the [__] last ac/dc song I
wanna hear yeah where's [__] night
problem yeah where's [__] uh what's
the next to the moon when is [__]
kicked in the teeth gonna teeth where's
the other one on them let there be rock
then it's just such a go down no it's
such a dangerous song smoke no cigarette
oh yeah I'm never genuine it's blues
chord on high overdose on you over don't
don't don't
yeah that Angus comes out
right so I wanna hear overdose I'm gonna
hear cell for those about to rock we
salute you like I want [__] you know I
don't want to hear that song yeah by
some deep cuts but the stations and the
advertisers let you you know I'm saying
that yeah like a living and they had a
music man that's what on that level on
my serious assumption Florentines very
good yeah awesome I was very drunk today
I listen to Norton revest all those guys
it's great
do I agree with all that stuff not
really but I tell you one thing about
Florentine he buys what he sells oh yeah
yeah like Jim buys what he sounds and I
can't take that away from whether or not
I agree with his music 50% of it I give
him props he takes his son to concerts
his [__] he's out there banging out
[__] a couple nights a week watching
bands I didn't even know existed
yeah and me and them are close to the
same age so I gotta get I gotta hand
them props you know but uh I think
sometimes I got poisoned with what now
poisoned like I got introduced to the
who when Led Zeppelin and the Beatles
and stuff like that but guess what I
guarantee there was a couple other
mother love bones that in you you don't
say oh yeah everybody always thought
that Soundgarden Pearl Jam with Seattle
sound no they weren't
it was Mother Love Bone yeah a lot of
people don't know that yeah Alice in
Chains blows me away they still do but
Mother Love Bone blow anyway yeah the
first sound guard now I'll still blows
me away
yeah Pearl Jam sound was great but it
was very commercial yeah it was you know
that whole [__] ham was very like
like lately I don't know what it is I'm
hearing the latter's Morrison every
[__] day oh yeah 1995 Jagged Little
Pill yeah Emily ow yeah
every day I hear her on e the eighties
music classic vinyl
everything she owned three syrettes
imagine man huh rich she is just drop
that out oh yeah that was like one of
the biggest selling records ever for a
while it was like wow for like one year
it was on the charts like
and you can survive off radio plays like
an amount of money oh wow I knew the
guys in Boulder who will believe cops
yeah the guys that listen to the radio
yeah
and mullets the music and see how much
you get paid and all that [__] they're
like residuals I knew those guys I'm
like for me I got that car wash
they got that car wash at the boat
that's classic oh wait so no lately I've
been feeling like maybe I got the same
broad deal for music that people are
getting today if economy they just think
that the comedians on Comedy Central all
that exists you know yeah so I want to
see some different [__] angles I mean
where how would you guys find new bands
before the internet because now I'm
imagining YouTube and Facebook and all
that stuff but how would you when you
guys were e25 what about that's what was
so amazing and I said we find music
before the infinite who heard a man this
is my brother yeah like I've always told
you there's no Yelp but I don't believe
Yelp I wouldn't go on Yelp for anything
I know Dean Dean comes to me and says I
had some healthier and it was great I
don't like out Dean so I know that him
and I don't match
but if Dean says to me I went to Rudy's
I went to Chandu these are my
restaurants I know I could take his
opinion for food and for movies and for
whatever I'm saying yep so you had
certain friends you had the friends that
were the people who wanted to be cool
you know I'm saying that yeah they want
the black t-shirts at the concerts every
line they let you know they went to the
show yeah those [__] clouds and then
you had people like Dean power and it
just went out four nights a week drank
got a package of [__] blow and rocked
out really rocked that with a band yeah
yeah really rocked out with a band you
know big [__] difference
yeah so I trust Dean if Dean comes up to
me he goes dawg I went to see Sabbath
the ni by God vase on the warm-up band
destroyed him thank God for Sabbath I
only played four songs yeah if they
would have done eight Sabbath will do I
had to run home and pack that bag guess
what I'm doing tomorrow
not even soon as Dean thousand Emily
lordy
you get their music no let's go to the
Sam Goody let's buy the album and a
cassette on the 8-track let's go yeah we
go we buy it we wrote we got a nickel
bag seven joints for five bucks Dean
what time's your mom get home 8:00 guess
we're going to your house won't smoke
the pot outside and we'll put the
[__] music on and that was it
other people who would do that like a
spy almost on the opening band because
most people didn't go to the opening
band right yeah well you know though he
always went to heaven man I have a
feeling since he's 14 he's done for the
opening band yeah when I was coming up
they told me not to go to the opening
band so I didn't go so one day I went I
got there early and I go why don't I
come here yeah it's like when you go to
the UFC in Las Vegas don't watch the
ender cards know when you got it no
people watch the undercard this guy no
no no when you go to the UFC anywhere
but Vegas hi guya
people are there that's a the fight
started for their there at Uli Anthony
yeah 2:00 in the afternoon there they go
on and then drunk it already ready to
[__] get high ready to have a good
time when you open up the doors when you
go into an event in a foreign city like
Milwaukee or New Jersey or Texas the
place is a packed by the time the
prelims are on go to a [__] fight in
Vegas yeah [__] shota Haven the main
card is on the main fight and people are
walking in like you're sitting in the
see how look at man I got third row and
all some people like actually showed for
this like really you got some [__]
pair of balls for fights later god I'm
sorry about this bottle got another
water yeah and you know I need
everything you got so sure that weeds
crazy Riley you know I've explained to
leaf Lee and I once when Lee and I
started working together yeah Lee really
high one
when I was on a roll in my living room
visit before the baby was ever even a
thought that whole okay and I wanted to
lead understand that you know without
Twitter I want you to think of a world
without Twitter without Facebook
what's the name of the band he went to
see you like well Dean sent me a picture
No yeah you know all Dino's on the way
out he looked at their schedule on their
[__] bass drum yeah and it said
Boston October so I don't know what you
gotta do you gotta get this band
whatever you know it that's that that
was it there was no website you didn't
go back to your hotel room and go oh my
god I love the band let's see where he's
from
you know nothing the name of the mothers
Led Zeppelin yeah that's it you had to
buy the album to get the information off
the album or get the cream magazine yeah
to read a bottom that was Italy that was
it but I still remember Lee and I
putting on rocks yeah and Mason's gonna
lease it now for a second there was a
rumor going around I still don't I'm a
massive plan is [__] there 38th
Street bargain North Bergen so many
[__] talent like talking the older
kids talking 76 I'm 13 yeah well you
know no yeah yeah I was 12 when they
were talking about it cuz I was saying
there was much done some kid was saying
there was mr. best know like [__] you
[__] idiot uh I would submit that the
junkies had done their breaking up in
also my three months later they release
rocks which is basically a [__]
masterpiece yeah yeah and I am a Sydney
and then going like how did people know
they're on him yeah like how did people
in yeah North Bergen New Jersey know
that Steven Tyler and Joe Perry would
stay word during the thing of rocks if
you read that book yeah I forget what's
the name of that they were on that holy
heroin they were one [__] major
league hair well that a Chinese got a
little bit the house making it uh-huh I
got a guy [__] at the house like they
were into it yeah how did my friends
know you know how did the word get out
let me ask you a question who gave a
[__] about Aaron
the Moores in 1975 yeah you got the
balls in the Psalter really well you did
why would I
did you see what Boston looked like last
night yeah did you see pictures of the
street yeah okay go check if the Boston
Celtics won the [__] championship in
75 the Red Sticks didn't won no but they
were good yeah and the England wasn't
that good no maybe they were they went
to the Super Bowl one time New England
think an 85 and they lost do you mean
quit Andre Tippett and those guys they
lost but Boston was the city I was
dominated by sports yeah it wasn't 85 in
the bill buckner 75 75 no no 75 was what
we're looking for you're looking for 75
35 okay okay okay they had 56 wins let's
see oh yeah uh I just want to see Tanya
the Celtics I don't know if they won
that year but they were in a bad team
the Red Sox didn't win the here but they
were in a bad team the bruins maybe what
will win but it was such a city that was
dominated by sports Aerosmith was just a
little part of that city there were
nothing last five dirty white boots yeah
blame [__] in the song you know I
mean different bars around the you know
Providence yeah so you're saying if like
they were from like Milwaukee they'd be
like the biggest thing ever okay just
just pick Milwaukee out of the van won't
Milwaukee at the time had the
[__] Bucks I'm sure through is
well I know ever I know what you say but
but just something about Boston Boston
had all four sports late right it's
really rough to give a [__]
plus plus Boston College you know all
those Boston College schools up there
they have it a lot of sports up there
for them to even give a [__] a little
bit about music and for this little band
to reach out nationwide with nothing but
you know they put bands on Midnight
Special downstairs and Don Kirshner's
rock concert it's not like they came
over tonight show no never I would never
want to
Jimmy Kimmel there is no baby there was
none of that Shawn Carson nothing like
that way so you really had a dig deep
for information wow that's crazy
you had to like there was no Jimmy
Kimmel I said nobody was there before
Jimmy Kimmel putting bands on it yeah
nobody yeah so how much of my band's
album sales were just Trump people
trying to figure out if they like them
well you know you just hear him at a
party like somebody put the record on
you're like who is that [__] is that
yeah and they go oh man I just got this
is the new such and such you know and
you're like oh god I gotta get that now
that's a good point you brought up Lee
about the how many people bought music
50/50 shot leaving me ask your question
okay if you walk into the store and you
see this album cover little of Def
Leppard high and dry it's a bunch of
guys looking up and then in the middle
of force picture in there with a guy
about to jump in a pool hanging upside
down pretty much and the pool has water
in it that intrigues your mind
okay that's 1981 look at the album cover
behind Dean doll right look at that
[__] album cover I would give you
$4.99 just for that just for this ain't
an artwork
look at that Zeppelin's - artwork look
what that looks like 50 years later yeah
so do you understand me the effort that
was put in to an album yeah why the
music industry has fallen to [__]
because you just made a great point Lee
if I walked into a store and I was about
to buy Led Zeppelin - because my brother
had it but I saw this yeah Dean whose
Def Leppard dog I saw them open up a
Judas Priest last year they [__]
killed it that album cover looks [__]
cool look at that house it looks at the
valley yeah [__] I'm gonna buy that for
$4.99 yeah we you're right record sales
did look at these covers me how can you
walk past this cover and sad the bloody
Sabbath if you turn it around
yes it's right there the front is the
devil getting him that's you tonight Lee
look at ya
let me see my Devils got Yardley the
devil has the front is the devil already
at the house but if you look at the back
the devil gone and you're in the bed
like people are talking thing ha ha whoa
you were in deep [__] 6 6 6 6 6
out front but if you turn it around
you'll see that it's a guy and his
family's around them yeah so I put
towels on his head no I don't you would
be pleasant I'll do this again you had a
scared s sativa you smoke that Joey deer
sativa oh my god great houses this week
like I said uh your boy gave you this
out here that's correct
I'm a god that's a [__] great
Armadale Willie Nelson city of New
Orleans the essential Johnny Cash yes
outside Johnny with la Bamba 'he's big
man you like this stuff d I don't know
this I know him but I mean I don't know
this record it's the UH it's the songs
by you boy that of Tom Tom Waits wow
this is cool
listening to it let me know what you
think all right thanks from Dante cos e
need a man of [__] steel this
is cool he also sent me a seed the almos
crash my [__] car listened to I don't
know what the [__] he's got he's got
noises people running around what's up
Lee huh what are you feeling dog [__]
them it's actually starting to calm down
which is nice that's calming down what's
it's just playing it's no no no it's not
calming down okay it's not just playing
games it's a dragon it comes and goes
okay well right now it's calmer it comes
and goes
we'll do another drop of a second
straight out yeah that's that's the time
when Dean and mr. Bozzio came on and I
held my puke until the end of the the
pod no he can't
no no t-shirt you leave some t-shirts
and the trunk that was awesome do you
feel the Ella booth way I could feel I
could feel the the the demon that the
hit of weed I talked that we were so
strongly imagine me I took a hit well I
don't know what happened to you
haha man I was you still stone yo yeah
totally but now it's just normal say
nothing you had me scared for a minute I
couldn't even see at all it was just
like I was this like complete paralyzed
the right side of my body
Wow and then I just started sweating it
was like I got bit by a spider for real
like a whole set as like I can't move my
right side that's how you lose a nickel
I saw you like looking at the water
bottle yeah two minutes later you
wouldn't yeah I just saw the whole
process like I'm gonna get that water
bottle I'm gonna get that one yeah right
I was like trying to reach it from my
arm wouldn't move it was like a
full-blown snake bite or spider bite I
just want to see where this drop was
gonna take this to them yeah it's pretty
good I like it now Wednesday I put three
drops different people pop in we're
doing now no not really
this is just a warm-up to Wednesday this
was just like spring training I've ever
been no no no this is nothing hold on
I'm gonna take over every sense with
with the SID
every time I come on you guys go next
level I would put three drops in each
one I got some Sydnor in the tub right
now yeah but where'd you gives you if
you don't wear mo no I mean yeah I get
so cool for nighttime
making the process and I gave Li the
light once tonight
ah but Wednesday went through the old I
can already tell [__]
will do three drops nine o'clock well it
pops up I'm gonna invite some people
three trucks nine o'clock delivered into
the top dick yeah it's like smoking dope
on periscope with Uncle Joe that's it
that's the new show on periscope three
drops tick-tock deeply this is it this
is there's gonna break my [__]
concentrate this is gonna get my
creative state back I really enjoy to
see the my issue was acid is just the
buildup
I freaked me out it scares the [__] out
of me
because of everything I guess that like
we're SCID as opposed to do to you and
then you [__] with me a little bit and
you know my brain just works like a
[__] hamster wheel and once you put
just like a little bit of like doubt
that I'm gonna start going crazy he
calls me like six I can be like another
tupperware today oh I can see light to
Mike when I close my eyes oh yeah we're
good we're good
this is gonna be fun one yeah you just
start and it just caused a lot of
anxiety but I'm having like I really
like this is what I like about acid is
often leave you by yourself
[__] it's like after after like the
build-up when the build-up is over it's
great it's just like life there's no
build-up if you do you see Li do you see
like when you're excited about a movie
yeah oh yeah you come home and you know
boy that Sun what made me go to that
[__] movie well the height right it's
the same [__] I do to you with the
ass no you know I'm sick and [__]
tired there's new America with their
with their fear and that you know
there's an age gap that just a scan of
everything in this country yeah they
gotta go home read the label no one is
gonna scare
to be honest nothing the only fear is
the fear that you put in your [__]
mind
I used to do this [__] after I started
doing this [__] heavy six months after I
found my mother dead on the floor oh my
god think of the visuals I would get at
night with this [__] wow man Ewing's
think of this [__] that would go through
my head with this [__] but guess what
this little drug helped me cope with
that tragic and a weird [__] way you
know I'm saying yeah I can't eat them I
started selling yeah now it's all 2 300
hits a [__] week Wow but I eat 2 or 3
a night how much is a head back then
yeah I would pay 90 cents for it that's
all for three dollars to ten a profit
who have it I want to see that
documentary I think comes out next week
mr. sunshine about the two dudes that
made the orange sunshine really yeah
orange sunshine that's the name of an
acid yeah so what does that mean when
you would name an acid what does that do
it's a different feel so is it just is
it marketing or is it that you would
market okay so they would have like like
that was liquid SID right but you don't
know what the name of it is it's all the
same yeah you know what yeah by Donna on
a piece of parrot Lee comes like this
thing if you came to my house Timon said
I want to buy a hundred its I give you a
piece of paper okay with what's that
call her fresh and perforations at and
once you cancelled all of them like they
would be like something it would be five
across and 20 down yeah be a hundred
hits and you'd have to take them all
either break them and put them into a
piece of paper but that would stick and
you would double up and give them away
hits or you put them in a little bit of
oil so you go out with a little falling
a little baggy and you just saw a little
before I put Maskull on there that long
it's the microphone yeah yeah but you
had your mic radhaji I get your are in
sunshine yeah your double-barreled
sunshine yeah the full way acid you had
the windowpane double window double
windowpane you had so many different
acid what are we on tonight that that's
what colleagues you see up there when
you looked at the hey it was a bat
that's what I thought about yeah he's
been you've been teasing me for ten
years about bathroom the rats and the
trees and I saw something applying
that's killer
that's perfect that's how you know it's
a good one because it's a closed door so
I'm telling Lee this [__] was the best
you know why because I used to go home
afterward and this [__] you think about
the [__] that goes through your mind it
really is amazing I understand what the
governor did testing on people with this
oh yeah there's been thousands of
different experiments just continuing
all that testing yeah but I tested on
myself [__] puke that gives us some
[__] guy yeah that's in jail for
final hauls a hit watches him scratch
his head for six [__] hours no no no
but it's I could see the effects and the
benefits of it yeah I'm telling you at
that age it pushed my mind a little bit
made me be a little bit more [__] out
not outgoing but understanding like I
used to see some dark [__] at night guys
yeah mmm yeah yeah man they saying that
you know that doing those low doses of
psilocybin you know it's a curing
depression and all kinds of stuff that's
cool get out like each day taking a
mushroom cap like in a tablet form and
then being better and you just build
your tolerance after a week for four
days on trip a little bit I'm diarrhea
yeah yeah after that you'll be tip-top
told Magoo you know say hey nobody
stopping you you balance your giggling
you're happy yeah I see it
I really see it I see this kind of
therapy and a lot of [__] when I
lived it it's not like I read about this
I read
let's [__] look at the facts okay I
was a wounded deer but what I was a
wounded deer I mean I was I was I was
damaged goods
why are you damaged goods because I lost
my [__] parrot it affected me I was
sideways Lee I was damaged goods at that
point anybody could come take me Isis
I could've joined joins town I could
have joined the cult I could've joined
the gang I could have been persuaded
because I was exactly how they want you
Jonestown I was exactly how they want
you I worked myself back to being
straight again and being knowledgeable
and yeah I lost it with the thievery and
the criminality and all that [__] it
wasn't who I really was but what got me
straight in a lot of those senses was
the thinking I do when I be high on acid
of what my future was of what I want as
stupid and as dumb as it sounds you know
yeah yeah you did it you should do
something in the last two hours oh yeah
oh yeah everything else goes home it's
you and your mind yeah and the darkroom
and sometimes you have weed sometimes
you have beer but the result is the same
the thought keeps coming up over and
over and over yeah and it forces you to
break [__] down what am I gonna do in
this situation and then it would force
it down for me you know I'm not I'm not
embarrassed to say this [__] I had a
situation where my mother had just died
that was a woman to do over it I knew I
was about to get thrown out of this
house on top of all this I was in love
with this broad and bro she just didn't
[__] water even if the first base in
me know
so whatever her and I would have an
argument about something I would put
Black Sabbath yeah sabotage on like take
a hit of acid and turn the lights off
and listen to both sides and after that
I'd have the answer to all my problems
yeah how is that yeah it's Tony better
Willie give you a breather yeah
[Music]
data down
to
you
I'm getting the [__] ain't no pauses you
were I can make no promises all the
noises front come on I'm being dull
right now that man I told somebody the
other day somebody called me poking some
[__] about how things weren't working
out for him and I said do me a favor
he followed Eden Delray he goes no I
don't I go follow Dean Delray that's how
you should be working if you're not
doing what Dean Del Rey is doing today
don't call me when you're doing that 90
days straight then come see me that's
good I can't divulge I said that yeah I
think he went into shock when I said
that took like a look at his tweets look
what he tweets look at his podcast look
at his consistency he talks about every
show he's gonna do whether three people
show up one show he don't give a [__]
he's relentless I don't know what that
comes with age because the person who
called me is like 30 yeah you know Ella
Norfolk there's an experience thing that
you know that's uh over and over and
over again type of thing and you're out
there working and something cracks
eventually it's better than sitting on
the couch totally well it's really great
to see what you do man I'm really proud
of your brand man thank you dan you're
not sitting there looking for handouts
you're always hustling you always put
your shows together you know there's
people that think oh I'm gonna you know
I'm just gonna wait till somebody takes
me on the road and that's it yeah do you
either go on the road by yourself you'll
take a huddle on a flight you'll sit on
the plane go to New York sleep on the
floor to do spots at the stand which
yeah to me is just you know you do four
spots a night I've even told me I'm
looking for spots they give me spots
every night I can't be mad at you for
something like that yeah
it's the [__] this whole game whether
it's music did you have the same work
ethic for music I did man what's great
about this is you if you have work ethic
or a drive and a couple down in a band
then you got an extra load on your
shoulders but with just comedy it's just
full on me you know so I don't have to
worry about anything
like I don't have to ask anybody if I
need to go out and work or what you know
like band member wise you just know
that's an everyday [__] thing mm-hmm
solid yet you have the same work ethic
for musical illusion yes yep absolutely
sometimes I'd have that wind knocked out
of me a little bit you know and be like
to em but then something would happen
and I'd be different swaggering through
you know do you get the wind my thought
you can calm me from time to time yeah
yeah man it's uh it's so much work you
know cause it's like you you could be
doing you know doing shows show show and
then I'll send in weeks no shows like
what it's going on here you know as far
as Road you know it's so weird how long
you know you do comedy twenty five years
you have to [__] that stopping yeah I
just got turned down by through high
level management themes was I depressed
I mean I wasn't happy about having to
pay somebody extra money unless they
were that good they were gonna bring me
that much extra film work with TV work
where I really didn't want to do you
know like I was thinking about yeah so
when they told me no like the people who
called me like bro are you sitting done
this is a really depression I'm like no
I'm not depressed at all yeah that means
nobody's gonna take my money and I still
control the [__] Kingdom you know I
didn't know how they were gonna come at
me or whatever or what type but to be
honest at this point the game I really
don't want that so I you know where I
was like kind of happy like relieved
like if I go with them gonna have to
have do certain amount of weeks on the
road or do this yeah that's where all
their other clients are doing and I
really don't want to do that man yeah I
think I've been tailing off the road a
little bit like I've been telling them
no
do a lot of [__] I'm pretty much home to
home Monday April Wow
really okay yes while I'm doing April
20th at Oxnard 4/20 oh yeah
it [__] Hawks not beside that I'm not
really doing much in April I got
theaters in May and Utah or something
crazy and I got like Kansas City or
something like that
in June or July that's it I don't know
don't you guys in the same boat as you
[__] I want to be at that yeah
I want to be a dad don't do the podcast
on my brother here have a great time and
do drugs and run up and down yeah yeah
makes no difference to me but I don't be
in [__] DC or anywhere else from
[__] Wednesday the Sunday night I
don't want to do that yeah not at this
point in my life I get it I like it how
it is I like it I don't need to go out
there and kill myself I'm not trying to
prove anything I'm not that guy man yeah
I'm very happy what's what's going on
right now so it's really we and how you
get the wind knocked out here but you
need that and at the end when you think
about you and you don't want yeah that I
even really want that what would I do
with that you know sometimes it's better
to want them to have you know so yeah
what's up bug you've seen things ah I
see you looking around like Kevin Lee
got shot what's the matter I'm okay I'm
okay I'm just
yeah I'm really deep deep I just really
speed you right now
that's me do you want to take a walk
around the block boy fee yeah no it's
okay you sure yeah I'll be loud I'll be
like Owen Benjamin off oh yeah
cross country skiing don't know where he
but he's I don't know where he is now I
keep all my Instagram he's country cross
country skiing uh-huh there's snow
around him he moves he moves he moves
till I upstate New York or something
right
yeah he won't good for him he had a baby
bro
yeah and he saw this for what it was and
he goes I don't want to stay here if
they want to hire me let them call me
I'll fly and take a plane yeah yeah
that's what it's become I think he does
his part
up there by himself yeah that's it
you know I can't be mad it can't be
Madeleine not everybody wants to live in
Los Angeles to raise a child yeah yeah
yeah yeah I'm on the fence though I'm
still on the [__] fence yeah the only
reason why I wouldn't leave is because I
don't want to move I know how much my
[__] pain the answer is yeah
especially if I got a move across the
[__] country with cats and wives and
babies and [__] it's not the same as
just moving across the street like no
really no idea when you land that your
destination your furnitures not there
for another week yeah and you haven't
live in a house with no furniture
vanilla we're gonna get then they try to
ransom your furniture yeah there was an
extra thousand dollars per mile so now
you're all nine thousand dollars you
have three days to come up with oh you
can't think you have no [__] idea
what are we gonna do with the cats then
the kid we have to put them all on the
same [__] vehicle and stop every hour
on the hour so the cats could get there
because they gotta be meow into debt
back there you want to shoot yourself
it's a 20 hour [__] ride where we got
to go with a child that means you got to
stop and sleep and take all those
animals out and guard the [__] truck
with all the furniture in it yeah
you have no idea yeah when you gotta get
up in the middle of night or bring a
friend with a trailer so he could sleep
outside close to your [__] furniture
yeah no ideally Syed yeah yeah no thank
you no thank you is [__] correct yes
yes what shows have you seen lately I've
been sensational
I've come to mind the last six months
[__] man why are you so Sabbath I mean
you go a lot yeah that Temple of the dog
was the one oh I was insane at the Forum
forum man I still can't believe how
great that was just blows me away man it
was just to hear those songs and then
they were doing some of the Love Bone
songs also so is
like oh my god couldn't believe it
Cornell sounded amazing you know not
talked to me about the form
yeah so a New York company was the
people run master guy oh yeah and my
heard day one in that and just it looks
and sounds it's insane what they did was
they they there used to be this amazing
video of it - that that LA Times put
together what was a speed shot of them
working for like a year and a half or
whatever but they dug down so the thing
kind of goes like this gradually you
know so every seat you're not in anybody
sightlines you know just kind of slowly
graduates up then they built all they
they had some guy come in and shoot
lasers or whatever and put the speakers
all over in the perfect spots it's
insane man in there then all the seats
made only for music now no sports at all
so it's just an incredible like that's
where he's going down yeah and it's I
mean it's [__] I mean the clap is
gonna be there yeah yeah it's incredible
dude how [__] old is Eric Clapton 70
yeah I think 70 70 to look that up
way I figure you 72 since this is it
yeah
god [__] bless him man yeah 72 still
a my music looks good he looks great
heroin for all those years was a dirty
[__] junkie Shh
it gives me hope yeah man that guy he
killed those guys are alive man
you know like 45 no yeah he ain't no
[__] phone no no she was born 1945
March 30 so it's 55 and 17 is what 72
yep yeah yeah
72 years old yeah you know like five
years ago he's going through changes oh
yeah yeah this is this this this has
changes what's happening is this crazy
audience oh it's the same stuff it's
just really you want available no oh
yeah yeah what we got left I don't know
any of any stars left no think so I'm
okay I'm okay it's uh I'm sweating it
out as I dare you to smoke some more
that weed no there's no more left others
no no [__] up thing is I had to go
first thing tomorrow I gotta go drop my
car off Oh guys I woke up this morning I
had a flat front tire
oh no okay no big deal Joey what the
[__] the big deal I was brain and hear
like a [__] this morning yeah
traffic was out the [__] Gazoo I said
[__] it let me take it to just eyes I
take it over to my man always just dyers
I know I'm gonna go get some coffee of
my wife call me calls me back goes yeah
you need a front tire 260 some dollars I
go white toilet 6 is unknown he goes
what I gotta replace both front I'll
take a listen I gotta bring back the car
to him too much yeah he goes what about
one tag right what's the one tire 168
yeah I go I don't want to pay 160 gate
for [__] two months yeah
so I call the Subaru guy and goes bring
the [__] card no I'll take it back
yeah I don't want bring I left four
hours to deal with that [__] this week I
got a new promo the [__] CD gets
released on Friday especially sure so I
had to do all this [__] promo
I don't have a four-hour window they're
gonna pick a card drive around the
corner do the credit app do all that
shit's it get the car explained to you
yeah then I'm starving I having to take
the wife to eat somewhere it's a [__]
nightmare
me next week I could do it so I went
through this d'armée naeun dude and he
said combine them one and we'll see if
we could plug it up if not I'll get you
a tire from the back and we'll hook it
up so yeah I don't know my day tomorrow
after I [__] did he drive over it or
something what do you think happened I
don't [__] know I was gone all
weekend I came home yesterday I drove I
went to yeah perennial I went to my
buddy's I made a stop beat but
everything was local I didn't go away
then once I got off the [__] plane I
just ran to Aaron - I don't went to a
Wheatstone with this unwanted there
somewhere along that [__] when I got
a nail on my god yeah ah witch who gives
a [__] it's gonna do with the price sex
we still gotta take forward but that's
what you wake up to on a monday yeah it
kind of sucks and I kept thinking let me
just put the bicycle tire on that
[__] I don't want your rainbow
fan bicycle 5 yeah so that thing is a
nightmare - now I gotta change the thing
twice why waste energy on me just
banging out the one time I keep putting
air in there and probably yeah yeah so
what's a half mass right now
yeah yeah but that's the work ethic you
have I could see that your work and I
always go I always look at Millie and I
sit here night after night having
conversations about different podcasts
what makes different podcasts work what
doesn't make it work and you're a great
example of what who is supposedly you
pull up you tweet it you tweet it again
you tweet it again you put a clip up
that's what you need to do in today's
[__] economy man to make a splash let
me guess you're gonna knowing about it
you have you had Bill Paxton last week
yeah how the [__] you scored that Savage
that's awesome as crazy as it might
sound you have guests that are actually
about the topic that you're talking
about it's it's amazing yeah how like it
especially like II like you like could
it be
bringing on a lot of comedians who might
not have like if you brought me on the
show I'd be a waste on the show yeah
because I don't know anything about
music but you bring people who actually
have interesting music things to talk
about and it's just great
man I had Joe Travers on today and he's
the guy who's in charge of the entire
Zappa
music collection
it's all on tape and you know the tape
can rot away and everything so he's in
charge every day full-time job of baking
the tapes keeping him conditioned
balancing him onto another piece of tape
all this it's like a a non-stop he has
'm the hands of a master record yep all
the masters and he's constantly working
with him because they reissued all kinds
of records and stuff all the time and
he's in charge he's cut the vault
Meister it's cool and he said there's
over a thousand tapes so imagine like
that's just a full-time job isn't that
cool
do you feel like you missed your calling
who me yeah no no I mean the vault vault
Meister maybe one of the interesting job
isn't somebody doing something aren't
they doing someone Prince's music all
right I heard it's going back on iTunes
next week you know what is his music
it's been off since that since he passed
so always it was taking a little fight
to them it was on for a while and then
he took it off and and then it was on
again and then he passed away and it was
gone again so I heard it's coming back
next week he was one of the last
holdouts I think member liked the
Beatles and him like five years I think
there's a couple people holding up yeah
there's even a ship DC for a while was
hold yeah I gotta find a lot of [__] on
there sometimes I asked my wife I get
back home sick it wasn't on it yeah I
look three times I went on the other way
I came from like that's [__] weird
that that whole yeah speaking of West
you let him drown
somewhere my wife we got a babysitter
we're gonna go to dinner come [__]
driver tonight stay with a haven't come
time yeah yeah and guys are our age no
you know stay where the heaven came on
Austin somebody from the neighborhood
died yeah you put legs up one two and
they'll said let's uh put forward there
and something about that soul you know
it's just something about that song that
even like I was right there as when it
came to mango Led Zeppelin was never
gonna lose that court case yeah it was
never gonna happen
they took thing the two dudes back to
the room and said listen this music has
become a part of American society
yeah let's pretend they stole the
quarters which you did yeah what you
[__] did you two nasty
[__] huh huh what you did yeah I
can't get mad did you listen to your
version yeah it makes you want to shoot
yourself
hahahaha makes you want to shoot
yourself I'm sure people say that about
my jokes maybe like hey man maybe
somebody can do that joke better but
yeah it's such a part of American
society at this point it would be so
destructive to go to for that song to
have an asterisk next to it like to go
out like Pete Rose yeah but you know Zam
like it would just be too much for that
song to go out like Pete Rose yeah and
might there I can't my goal this song
could never ever get a song you know and
I know that there's YouTube videos yeah
I mean there's facts those songs are
facts but listen to those songs they
weren't going nowhere yeah three black
dudes yelling about something I don't
know what them there's one something you
listen to they yell at my son get [__]
clean the lab I'm sorry guys his $50 is
a bottle of wine do we change the law
right that's always ours
it's crazy what they did is up curious
but they took everything to a different
[__] level oh man
you hate to say all this [__] as a
comedian and whatever the [__] we do you
know you don't want some of the pilgrims
in your jokes or whatever but this is a
different type of pilgrimage they said
listen we're gonna take this and make
this 20 times better it was and we're
not gonna give you a dime for it yeah
we're just gonna show you what way you
[__] up yeah you know stairway to
heaven solo to this [__] oh it's the top
it's Jimmy Page's soul it's just some
solos that you listen to them you know
who's [__] around who's doing it for
the girls you know what solo has always
killed me Angus on touch too much at the
end oh and the the one on that 104 when
we talked about overdose that's one of
my favorite guitar pieces by him he just
gets down and dirty like the feeling on
the end there he's just going for when
bonds just keeps going you're as tough
as [__] nails let me give some
shoutouts here real quick Andrew Rogers
I love you Peter men deburr Jeffrey
Collins always on point live like J
barely legal
Michael Ziegler Donovan Sickler
Alexander Gonzales and my main man oh
the king of sling and dick Kerr and
Michael you know I love you
[__] don't forget Valentine's
Day I'm and flappers and don't forget
the 23rd to the 25th I'm at the house of
comedy a Minneapolis [__] how
you like me now and [__] and we go up
there freeze my ass off in Minneapolis
but I don't give a [__] but wants to go
beach town in the summer you want to go
on it is natural [__] habitat you
understand merely stop breathing very
I'm gonna send you home two people
jobless on
I have pyjamas on man yeah who doesn't
like pajama for the Super Bowl you
probably have slippers in oh I don't
like slippers so you just sat there with
those two hopes just hang it up there
marinatin yeah those Jew hopes you can't
I can't get too excited boy he's got a
lush woods though yeah it's a toe that's
as hard as [__] stone he ever taps
you whether you're going down it's like
a steel boot yes to help kick me one
time in jujitsu my leg was swollen for
three weeks
oh my god wash would stow it got Bert ah
that's nicely [__] it up and [__]
please ride that acid yep
he's going deep into the yeah how's it
treating Lily I'm okay I'm uh I feel
like this isn't another down period you
hungry no that's how you know it plays
if you leave this ass is gonna play with
you or my canister a weed over there
yeah mm-hmm well I leave them put that
in the middle of the table when I come
back the mama to be empty cuz that's
gonna be your answer right there that's
how you smoke that with the savage
tonight your business ideas are gonna
come to you wife's ideas are gonna come
to you you know I have all the answers
to your questions I'm gonna leave you an
album in there I'll leave you in my
sound to meditate that what do you think
we should leave my Johnny Cash
essentially just sick that was awesome
hahaha how many time did you trip
growing up brother well you know I liked
mushrooms way better I was the opposite
I took acid like four times once was at
a concert and that was like whoa he hit
her man like way too strong I remember
it felt like the stadium was breathing
like this and I was just like oh I
better go ride this out it was like
Motley Crue Whitesnake yeah it's funny
when you connect the breathing with the
wall you know that's happened to me with
anything with the TV with
a picture a mirror oh my god yeah my
computer spins freaking me out right now
oh my god you trip in front of a mirror
that's like torture yeah especially when
you catch yourself tripping and you see
yourself in the river tripping like the
devil's advocate yeah Lee stop rubbing
your head stop looking in the mirror
shut the computer down I'm not looking
in the mirror I'm just I'm just sweating
profusely
look at you Lee hasn't even hit me
that's how hey that's how I felt it all
right now weed oh my god he's on the
weed and you know what I put two drops
in this how they do it yeah because I
put one at the house two times I'm Joey
two times yep yep
Joey two drops yeah my own sugar cubes
next time box of those things lis oh I
have a box of sugar cube my wife found
them the other day she's like what the
[__] it eat yeah I show this to the debt
yeah [__] is wrong with you
she just walked out of the room she said
that hilarious
it didn't hate you uh I feel something
but not I feel the edibles I thank you
guys I feel something I'm a mutation oh
my god [__] it's been it's sad yeah it's
very sad it's very sad to know that I'm
kind of immune to this [__] that's crazy
right like haha it's not that it doesn't
affect me I won't even let it affect me
oh yeah like I've done it so much like I
can control the whole thing through
breathing but it is crazy every nice if
you taught me any of these breathing
techniques or any of these tips
that's a where is you gotta clear your
mind every time listen man
I think about this show all the time I
write about it you know because I'm
interested in human behavior my biggest
asset years and masculine years and all
those giggly years yeah was from 80 to
about 83 where I giggled every weekend I
had oh I would die yeah you know and the
last hour the trip was me alone coming
down thinking about what was going on in
my life breaking it down you know trying
to put everything in place but those six
or seven you know Talent
yeah well you met with your friends of
sex oh yeah I weighed them at 6:15 with
beer yeah 8:30 you're fired
oh absolutely you've been into people we
like we this is a different experience I
would head straight to the wood so what
time is it now and on in that time line
we took it at 7:30 right 7 o'clock right
at 10 o'clock
you'll be on fire if everything goes
well what time is it now I know you
don't know how to get [__] go to the
hospital in time with the dances and
hours ago give me the [__] detonator
what's it something give you yeah when
you get stuck by snake what do they give
you the anti-venom and develop you tell
them to give you the anti-venom until
hospital there were no I'm just teasing
it if you want you go now I want to go
over there and tell them to give you
some charcoal I don't like it at the
hospital take your name and number
they'll give you a peek through the FBI
just like a house cope up your ass to
see those you got a dick that's already
there now is all this happen so I didn't
Lena know before you go to the hospital
okay I'll look for Warren still see if
your jaw molested you go in there with
that green t-shirt on you know
Harry airy yeah I shouldn't have gotten
Dean Hine tonight that was a mistake
I didn't no no it's fine it's good no I
didn't know wasn't a flattened Dean that
really did I thought your tolerance is a
little high
oh now I could see you wanted to play
with fire when you walked in he was
snooping around but yeah containers yeah
look on that pipe son you got something
in your mind I didn't even offer it to
you yeah people think like it was gonna
I don't like you know listen Ben the
best part about people who don't get
high is when they do take a hit yeah
they go deep and it's enjoyable for them
total I know eat after this like you're
gonna leave here yep
and you stopping somewhere we should it
for like no no no still you're off it oh
yeah how long nine months now how many
pounds 36 no sugar
yeah none that's for breakfast together
I will I wake up I have either
steel-cut oatmeal or I do a protein
shake and a piece of toast with the
almond butter and some fruit we would
die if you haven't brother he's a toast
and strawberries and and blueberries
myself no meat no oh well that I have
meat at lunch what do you have for lunch
then lunch I usually do like you know
like let's say either eggs
you know like for lunch like a omelet or
some quinoa and [__] like that black
beans chicken original Joe's a little
quinoa
no not nothing not there when I'm there
I was just there with Russell Peters
what did you thought I ate the I got
green beans and the hamburger steak yeah
man I'm not a prett no bread Zeki Oh
bread remembered I can eat that
kikyo right were you thinking nothing of
the zekiel died happy
in two weeks you'll [__] be ripped to
shreds lee if I came in here with his
eagle bread he'd throw me and Brett off
let me ask you something Kenny chicken
wings out of this diet he can but not
the breaded ones what about the ones
with Frank's hot sauce yeah
she could eat those yeah then I'm not
sure going that Frank's hot sauce it's a
little bit it's not like ketchup or
something there now she'll eat ketchup I
don't I go mustard mustard has no sugar
no I love mustard I love mustard I love
it hello my hamburger
oh good googly mooglies dude said I wish
I had it now with no bun nobody little
ham for a little mustard on it you
[__] put it in a lot of people use
mustard in sauces yeah like the base it
would be a mustard never and it's
[__] delicious oh I didn't know it
was I don't know about me and I chef I'm
just a fat [__] I love it you know hobby
boy has me find love I got a little
money I don't know yeah if I got a pound
chicken I'd rather get raped
uh-huh I got a perm like a chicken
cutlet see what the chicken really looks
like yeah pause and [__] everything I
don't want to see nothing all right
I see no [__] animals in this
primitive phone I want to see in the
last condition that's I wanna see the
head the hosts in the eyes I don't want
to see what it looks like raw I don't
know do I want to [__] see it nothing
yeah give it to me well done or medium
rare butterfly that [__] and put
some sour cream mashed potatoes let me
go to work yeah oh yeah a chopped salad
yeah look at leas floating now it's all
over leave me one more drop thank you
you wanna smoke a bowl sure cuz I'll put
a drop in the bowl yeah I said this oh
[__]
last week tell them what we smoke we
smoked the mushroom last week and the
bomb I smoked a lot sure [__] you all
right Michael
karynda's he saw the devil yeah look on
these freakin ass oh look I'll be
sweating from his stomach
yeah quietly you're working yourself up
into nothing sweat dude coming out of me
no no buddy I see you're working
yourself up it's not working yourself up
all right
with family I mean you're making noises
you're thinking about what's Paul are
gonna say you're 28 years old even
Captain Kirk an enterprise you
understand you don't have to go see dog
movies all right dog movies that's
hilarious
I like that dog that's when I was really
tripping when he was talking about that
and he said what the [__] and I couldn't
even comment yeah I used to go to I
think I've been to Barney's Beanery
twice and both times I got sick yeah and
go there I used to go to that Hollywood
one right there you know it's a freaking
town yeah Rock that's why I was yeah
they have pool tables yeah but I didn't
write that if you do I didn't really eat
there you know I mean forget what I went
there for manager's meeting once or
something yeah once you people met and I
was gonna meet people have to like the
Comedy Store spot for a football game
and then there was some crazy people
then and that was it I've never really
done a big then I went to this one to
watch a UFC fight oh yeah well up the
bottom flap is I went there with my
family my wife I thought yeah shoot me
that's the one I went to yeah one over
there but mr. turkey club over you yeah
unbelievable turkey club turkey on that
[__] Club oh yeah turkey club various
I don't want a burger now I want to go
with you these one of these next shows I
gotta get out of the house at night I
got to make a change
yeah that's Jerry I don't Paul Mooney
always said if you want to write good
material gotta be entertained they're
really right you gotta be always
entertained you know and it makes sense
I try to entertain myself with various
different [__] ways and tortured
people but it's not enough anymore
this is not the table for me
wait you will live your whole life
without eating an edible you would have
never thought he probably yeah you
would've never thought of smoking
you would have smoked twice more in your
life you would have been staying at home
every night in Boston at the movie
theater you would have probably had a
different job by now you don't got to
visit mom three nights a week and get a
free meal I know you yeah you want to
drove the hour take how your horizons
have changed it's crazy
it's submit you got a girlfriend if you
do some acid we do some mushrooms
everything is in moderation
it's like we're out Friday and Saturday
night drinking saying that's the
government's here no this is perfect
mmm when they will go for drops I
thought we put two with the four drops
and ones that I really get the bodies
before drops that's when you wake up
with the ambulances what happened yeah I
just jumped off the [__] building
over here four drops man Joey for Joey
four drops leave for drugs uh-huh
because I did a drop at the house I let
it melt and I put another piece here oh
that's so funny
oh my god breathe breathe out your nose
come on that's stop thinking about I'm
not thinking about anything I'm sitting
here having a conversation with my man
then there is E and I'm see like I think
it's not coming from me they're coming
for you and look at the assets in your
pocket no it's not this is not [__] I
put in your jacket pocket don't have a
dick how much fun you bet we have fun
[__] yeah it's fine you die you didn't
get sick it's not like we're shooting
heroin so I get drinking fifty two shots
for no reason we just think this was all
right dose two hits is only those lis
know what you're talking about but no
tomorrow we'll do four and then next
week we'll take it to eight six bow
until we finish it this is the this is
Black History Month
was celebrating Black History Month out
of respect for Frederick Douglass people
been bad-mouthing him lately and we'll
never do acid [__] every other
podcast as much yeah poor Lisa he's
thinking about moving home look at the
once a week twice a week yeah went
through the whole front month of
February on the headless it does that
for Black History hit a Sidman thank God
I always do this I had to sit for myself
how ass what's the next band you would
wanna play if we go see man I'm hoping
to see Metallica this Sunday at
palladium was it sold on well I don't
know what's going on it's like they're
playing the Grammys and then that night
they're gonna do a show at the Palladium
and I it's like Citibank putting it on
or something but I'm trying to get into
that
okay so Citibank it's for Citibank card
holders it might be yeah or could be
also fan club I don't know but I'm gonna
get in somehow I gotta have a luau oh
that's incredible
come on yeah I can't believe it come on
I swear I can't believe it out oh yeah
yeah it was number one for a couple
weeks what a [__] to what I live yeah I
gotta get my life together oh I
understood the album was coming out oh
yeah it was number 100 for two weeks oh
yeah let me get you a song off this
certainly look this one up okay dude
this thing is I didn't [__] know this
nobody tells me dickly you begin a
charge of music but if I'm attracting
music we're gonna be stuck pretty small
it's time we both got our act together
we we gotta get on top of this ship a
bit more hi Iranian Bozzio okay Lee yes
sir put on this song right here I can't
read right now okay spit out the bone
Metallica
you got here without the [__] bone
yeah wait to hear this
he's 32 30 33 this year yeah there you
go
Lister this
you
oh my god that was great when it came on
he just no oh my god whereas I always
thought that people just retired one
day's so they're all these years they
only had one person they'll change the
bass player don't left that time uh two
different bass players one died then
they got a replacement Jason and then he
quit and now they have the third base
but jason has his own bed though no he
he did did yeah and then I don't know
what happened he put out a thing called
Newsted like two years ago was smoking
and then it just stopped it was awesome
man
so the new guy that Trejo yep what's his
name yeah it's it's uh I'm telling you
this [__] makes you forget this year's
will get ya right Trey helium-4 Helia
yeah he's good he's good yeah he's all
right he's all in oh yeah he's I mean
he's great
it's like well bandanna come from he was
in suicidal tendencies pretty sure
that's the band with that up we it's
suicidal tendencies I'm pretty sure sure
he leo
how do you spell the name Trujillo he
are unit J ILO Trujillo Elio no [__]
trumps nephews over here at this point
I'm supposed to be able okay yeah I have
a Spanish accent I'm smoke up his groups
it's right there his groups
yeah bands are discography yeah
understood
he's a lot of them he has Jerry Cantrell
Black Label Society infectious grooves
suicidal tendencies suicide tenets lens
hyped in mass mental all the Osborn when
Tipton yeah make this guy's [__]
experienced oh my god yeah yeah he's
been through the [__] yeah he replaced
Rudy Sarzo
yeah yeah yep here's an Aussie you know
he was nación yeah he played nosy [__]
so these guys get stronger and they just
move into stronger bands it seems like
yeah why is there so many personal
changes in heavy metal now I think it
still comes down to money you know like
the lead guy this long without taking me
what yeah what's he pay his band give me
an example of what is going on in the
music industry like I don't know what
those guys are making now but let's say
a big guy but back then was probably
making like we have five grand a week
plus per diem
you know maybe more I don't know all
right well the Eagles incorporated yeah
it was Glenn Frey the drummer yeah Don
Henley and they put the other guy here
Joe Walsh but the guitar player and the
other guy at work were [__] employees
yeah nice money I'm not gonna lie to you
oh yeah money but they were employees
they got nothing from the recording
nothing right yeah I think so they I
think they were just like hired
when did they get brought on today well
when they did that reunion tour they
went out with all the guys right you
know but eight what happens is those
dudes that quit and then the other dudes
keep it going and then the guys that
quit go hey I want to come back and
they're like well you quit four years we
kept this gone so you can't just step
right into the same partnership yeah oh
man what is the usual partnership like
if I let's say tomorrow
[__] Soundgarden fired him whatever
yeah and I became the top layer you
would just be a hired gun that's it yeah
forever because once the other three see
the more money the price ergo that
they're not gonna ever there like with a
higher guy and a man why chisel others
that guy gonna be in on recording
sessions doesn't he get a cut of the
recording sessions then dope take care
of yeah yeah he'll might not like what
everybody else is getting if he comes up
with something then he could get like
songwriting credit why there were you
know working on music but some bands you
know I think look at it was like well
you know you're hearing a boy so you
work for us so you record your tour or
whatever you know I mean look at you
right now right now you're an
independent contractor you don't have an
agent you got a guy that's helping you
manage he helps you book some stuff but
pretty much you do all the bookings I
don't have any manager oh no I don't
have any manager or agent you're out
there a lone wolf of society yeah okay
sorry you're a lone wolf aside you got
to bang it out for two more years and
finally this young kid
that grew up with a dad who's a rocker
it's an assistant somewhere yeah he's
gonna come up to you and go hey man I
really dig it
I've been trying to talk this guy my
idiot boss into [__] booking him but
he says you need to be a little bigger
I believe it how about I put you in like
six seven weeks you know and you and him
put six or seven weeks together you make
a little bit of money
the Alea this guy gets promoted he's a
junior agent and [__] Gersh Dan
you're his first client you know so now
you could spread his wings a little more
now you got a raise you're selling
tickets
ba boom then you get another raise with
this guy so not you've probably got like
three raises you've been with him full
of five or six years now you have to get
a manager you're not making top top
Kevin Hart money so you don't really
have to worry but you're making money in
an age where every dollar counts yeah
you know 22 no more I'm saying yeah yeah
yeah at some point you want to skip away
from the game by a ranch somewhere and
that's it play the guitar and watch your
toenails grow yeah that's the track I
don't care yeah but the [__] it is yeah
you'll still make some money and you'll
still do this and you still do that but
for the most part dad do you feel it's
fair that this manager comes on you have
to give him everything you're making
when you and this other guy he's been
booking you for five or six years he's
gotten you in a pretty good [__]
money I come in here I'm like I'm gonna
be a manager Dean that right you have to
give me 10% erode money
the same road money that you and I that
you and this agent have been working for
yeah how do you feel about that man
I never deal with them do you say listen
I can't give you as much as him because
he's been here from day one
well yeah I think people will take a cut
because they're like at least they're
getting something you know part of the
money you know I what I always would do
is like if somebody wanted to manage me
I would say okay anything that you get
and bring to me we'll split whatever
I get is just on my own well that's me
that's my philosophy tell her all the
way through yeah if you got your name on
my IMDB and you got your name on my
other thing that you put supposed to
submit through and some other [__]
calls me at the house guess what I'm
cutting you the [__] out obvious that
[__] didn't stick out you better change
the name of the company to a lot of a so
they can see it first because really
that's what yeah four years I got that
yeah they call you still have to pay the
Vig yep they know that if they don't
call the agent they save three hundred a
little better hotel room a little bigger
trailer you know what a good agent you
get all these little things I got your
gal more water yeah I got your mustache
I got you this without that agent you
won't get those little things that's
right that four years yeah and you see
the difference before being a [__]
greedy [__] for a ten dollar difference
yeah one day I just said no you gotta
call my agent and once I started telling
people to call my agent guess what
happened yeah I'm no word yeah yeah yeah
a lot of people know [__] of agents yeah
yeah you know it's so creepy they're
looking for people with no agent yeah
it's like they're going like this job
pay scale plus you get a hotel room okay
totally and two years later you find out
that the guy that was kamek they
couldn't shine your shoes
he was at three yards yes what they were
playing him they were paying him 2,500
an episode yeah a hotel room a plane
ticket and meanwhile you're like what
the [__] did I do yeah
if I would've got an agent that have
half a heartbeat he really got me so
[__] don't you know yeah I got a guy
left and I feel bad about not the
sharpest guy in the shed but I love him
because he'll do exactly what you tell
them to do yeah and that takes balls
yeah he'll if you tell them listen Tom
fifty thousand for a roll they ain't
gonna give you 50,000 for a row you just
have a good time and send this guy in
there fifty thousand so are you back
stuttering likely listen listen listen
damn was hung up on me but listen it's a
good thing they really wanted yeah they
really watch it so maybe you're not
gonna give you fifty thousand yeah it's
off the table
they movie joy that's why I tell you
50,000 because I don't want the role yes
yeah yeah yeah I want you dumped to hang
up on you
yeah just one roll these people would
not leave me the [__] alone
I never seen with one arm they wanted me
to put a tuxedo on and tuck my arm away
behind my back yeah
and I had one arm onstage they couldn't
figure out I was gonna do it anywhere
from $100 to 2,000 a day Wow that time
what's his age you'd beat him up I kept
saying get him a 1500 then he would call
me bugging you're gonna confirm like
that and I go get him for 17 Wow I had
this guy going in and out there haha
how about 10 days like an animal that he
is he had to deal the entire time this
is a hundred I'll blow budget film yeah
I said for them before I go in then
let's send me the [__] cast list I
want to see it wasn't this movie there's
nobody
yeah holiday so I said [__] Godzilla
in it yeah like I said Godzilla's not
the smartest guy but he'll go in there
like a [__] hell like nothing dog
yeah yeah
I call them back get me 250 yeah go for
250 yeah do you want to commit let me
check my date I'll call you in the
morning then I'll call him in the
morning of those dates are they good get
him for 500 the [__] day for a nickel
we wife [__] with him for five or six
days I did this for a while with this
dude that is so they finally some
[__] 2000 flat a day three days oh my
god it was a score yeah I just did from
a hundred yeah yeah we worked them from
a yardstick yeah [__] you in your head
allowed a movie and then moved to
California doing a lot of [__] day
movies ain't talking about money on the
podcast but I want you guys don't listen
to this no that don't come to you no all
we can give you something hours a day
but meanwhile they could give you
$10,000 a [__] day I just don't want
to do it and they are giving $10 and
they are given 10,000 the people who
have like a good agent tell us or
somebody who asked for it I finally real
listen if you don't ask for it you're
not gonna get it yeah the worst maker
says I can't do that but they're not not
gonna give me the job so aspart yep
if I don't want to do the [__] job
I'm gonna hit him with a number that
gonna rock their [__] world yeah I
want them to hang up the phone
and that's okay I didn't want to do the
job yeah you know I don't want to be in
that movie I don't want to do this under
so yeah you have to ask for your valleys
sometimes what you see yeah you know the
problem with comedy is that when we get
here we judge our value on how funny we
[__] discuss getting a TV show my
phone in it yeah that I killed behind
them at the store I'm telling you he
can't follow me
he gotta follow me at the cafe so like
he couldn't find you know Oh that [__]
just goes in your mind and then one day
you realize the business aspect of it
yeah it's like even with the Twisted
Sister document that we spoke about
they were the bank account and nobody
wanted assignment yeah sometimes that
happens you know how frustrating that
feeling that's gotta be crazy right my
Cadillac was in a vault is that what you
said no tell there's in the wall I think
that the catalogue was there like their
catalogue was in a vault or something oh
no that was the podcast that I was
talking about a few hours ago no it just
was white right now never mind okay yeah
this is no we're talking about the
Twisted Sister document right how many
times they failed and even this was a
guy this was a band who had an audience
then all you had to do was sign up you
were gonna start making money right away
I got a signle and start from scratch
and put them in Tuscaloosa yeah then
build them up does that bus hop the
money listen here's the money machine
dawg
so it's pretty interesting that no
matter what level you always get [__]
home some bum I'm sure any Murphy wants
more we say you don't get yeah yeah sure
even stars like that I wanna I read that
script I'd be perfect for it now I
[__] you yeah
you're 20 years too [__] old stupid
ha ha ha change the whole direction of
the movie cuz you want to try to make it
come back suck my dick
there's yeah they're hustling scripts to
tell her you know when you're not
working you're hustling scripts of you
are not well or not even if you're well
a home that wants to sail away into the
night in this [__] society yeah
what I [__] working you know
I don't like I said I don't have the
patience to look at scripts no more they
all understand I'd only do the podcast
if the animal planet thing works so beer
I'm ready to work with cats if it
doesn't I'll move the [__] law yeah
I'll pitch a different idea you know but
something that's gotta be in a micro
setting I'm not like I'm not ready for
all that [__] that anymore that's yeah
yeah yeah
I'm fluent that [__] I just want to do
melee a bowl and let's go let's shoot
this [__] you got it yeah move on I
gotta sit here for two hours you didn't
turn the mic on go [__] yourself yeah
that's the quickest way to [__] get
me about the chat that [__] evening
any more waters yeah yeah oh yeah
everybody's [__] thirsty leave one
another water you drink on any wall you
got dehydration that acids burning a
hole in your stomach
yeah what I'll do is give me a [__]
water with a little acid
assload dilute it's like a mild coffee
water you got a flashback don't ever
happen to you do we get [__] up on
boxing oh yeah nice team Jack Daniels
that dude ooh
every time I smelled it just vomit you
lookin like you would took like vodka
nice tea yeah there's a home then you
wake up a little like to get some a
drink of his iced tea oh it tastes like
ass it still tastes of ocular that's
what I'll give you I'll give you that
come on Lou yeah like a Cosby all of a
sudden I'll go for five [__] days you
better you me anything so you do a
theater and then the width February 18th
on a Saturday night Saturday night doing
the suti at row theater and if you punch
in the free code of candles lit you'll
get a discount but yeah that's gonna be
interesting I love Denver man doing
comedy they're one of my top he
contacted you out of the blue yeah he he
listens the podcast and I think he saw
me the last
was headline and out there and said hey
you want to do it and I said what let's
do it he he's done it right man he made
an ad
he's got radio ad and I got kind of a
little cheap TV spot yeah he's gone for
so he's gonna friend everyone with that
mouth love it love it man
while you're there you'll see a show a
to you flying on the 17th early you can
fly Burbank Southwest that's the best
like a doctor right to them two hours
you asked a lot I take the early went to
the first non-stop ER out there great
you do Burbank you're with her Bank oh
my god back Sunday on the Lord's Day no
problem nobody got their feelings hurt
awesome I it's a beautiful [__] thing
you know it's funny how I get kind of
[__] up with stand-up but once you're
up to it even like a natural like I said
Friday and there's none of that rough
[__] sets the early shows but once I
get into the flow that I'll murder you
you know I'm saying the only problem is
that no material I got wasn't doing
anything right I fractured on it by far
I had just got rid of it I'm like this
[__] ain't working oh man this [__]
ain't working I'm not trying this [__]
know my way back and put an extra
material the little book with the date
on and I'm done yeah this was a lot
funnier on paper than what it was on
stage this was a lot funny in my head
than what it really was on [__] stage
Wow how long were you in on it 20
minutes I thought I had 20 minutes of my
first 20 minutes I was excited this [__]
was like doom getting kicked on me I
tried it the other night too and it
didn't work
Who am I kidding I was just forcing it
and I'm like this ain't working yeah
then I watch bill bird special the other
day and it makes you feel bad as a comic
but then it shouldn't because all that
is as a result of hard work yeah totally
he writes every day yeah you know he's a
[__] comic strip TV show or his
stand-up he dedicates real real time to
it I think my help
don't you know he's about to go into a
different realm fatherhood yep it's a
different set of [__] materials and
jokes you know which I've opened up
about a little bit but yeah really it's
like you gotta keep something close to
your heart and Ryan's your Idol I still
don't know how to uh act towards it like
it's not like my whole [__] Act
because let's face it I got a [__]
disgusting thoughts going through my
mind you should different times of the
day yeah I can't just say I'm a fool but
I'm [__] bad I feel this way I'm
giddy and I fly around what butterflies
is [__] yeah cuz I really don't he's
still gotta figure out how to keep the
lights on and totally how to [__] and uh
you know keep doing what you do and get
your rest and be healthy you know it's
so weird how we both turn into the
health thing the last couple years yeah
once you this is this [__] we couldn't I
tell me all the time you know there was
this [__] that we didn't take care of
when we were 30 and 32 that comes back
to bite you in the ass
hey Desmond and then later on you gotta
go back to these - drastic measures
anyway yeah if I could have done it all
over again I would I got rid of stoner
when I was like 25 I'm gonna get rid of
juices yeah you know holy I would have
continued my exercise routine even if it
was something at home if I couldn't make
a move to the gym I'd still do 50 squats
50 pushups 50 burpees you know yeah I'd
still try to do all those things you
know sleep sleaze Christ that's love I
casted sleep off for about 10 years yeah
that's exactly one that ages you yeah
that's the one that [__] up your
biological clock that's the one that
[__] up your central nervous system you
know when you're doing bumps of coke at
4:00 in the morning yeah and you have a
slept for 20 hours it does something to
you oh you know I doing math or whatever
the [__] you're doing it shots this
central you know that's why the first
year acupuncture she said to me she goes
I'm just getting rid of trauma
yeah all the trauma your body went
through I got to get rid of it one step
at a time little by little you know and
then after that then I got a heal it
then I have to build your Chia but for
starters I got all that [__] traumatizes
your body's leaving in a van yeah you
know bombing drinking whiskey bad [__]
yeah yeah whose [__] marks on every
level you know dirty food I got the
dying I was 4 mm mm mm yeah was just I
went on this [__] sabbatical a Dada
started making 99 you know yeah my
metabolism shut completely down I wasn't
living in Boulder anymore I wasn't
living with the high altitude which
burns calories naturally I wasn't
walking anyway no I'd become a road
comment yeah and instead of taking
advantage of the gyms at the hotels is
[__] I wasn't doing that either way Eton
mean that you know like on your wins I
was never listen I controlled myself
yeah after I moved New York City the
fried stuff oh yeah the mozzarella
sticks but how would you like that I
love it but inside that shit's death
cycle from look Bergen New Jersey with
Italians were [__] room yeah I think I
read three much of our sticks in my life
and that's it I love only me no little
mozzarella stick like a money I don't
know what's around oh man I never saw
one of those things in the [__] these
cups [__] love those things I like
what Lutz
yes life spin on a [__] prosciutto
sandwich with some roasted peppers this
[__] yeah some vinegar no I'm goin
[__] huh but none of this [__] I
don't know what the [__] you talkin
about I really know yeah oh you gonna
give me the paperwork Eliseo usual stare
at the [__] space and look around
maybe but haven't pajamas on [__] see
you ain't that badly I'm fine I'm just
it circles around me yeah I just heard
that so go around to me well do another
drop a little water looked a little a
little water below on the visit give me
water
give me half drink it down so I'm gonna
blow off I'm the one who
bro it's gonna calm me down and I can
see it already
I could see in your forehead you losing
energy
[__] this is like the red trust me I've
been doing this for 30 years
yes I'm like that wouldn't [__] live
when you're the number one [__]
producing the game I'm gonna lie to you
though hey you made [__] mincemeat
out of nothing look at you Oh were they
rubbing your little chubby good Jewish
head in the [__] thinking about the
numbers when he gonna tell Paula Paula's
gonna find that no I don't care about
that she's sleeping
yeah you got a cool one oh yeah she's
really my shoes want to take a drop over
to drop Joey to jobs wherever she works
not the courthouse but hey wherever she
will have lost stuff give a little blast
of this in the morning
no but Joey two drops are looking for
fun the more before she takes the train
see what happens give us yeah see what
happened what's gonna happen
she ain't gonna be mad at you you can
open up her Minds gonna sit there you
know watch Law & Order with her and it
all come to it yeah she stays home
that's good yeah you're talking about
which is already at work when this
happened no no you tell him not to go to
work that you dosed her just dough so
when she's in the shower she comes feeds
breakfast at dosed listen let me tell
you some you know I love you can't go to
work like whoa and sick why because in
16 [__] seconds you gonna start
feeling things down your spine and [__]
it's gonna hit you heavier than that
hits me I've had basic training with
uncle Joey you've had no training yeah
haha make neither half-assed on we
giggle like two [__] Momo's I'm just
dosing you it America's finest [__]
look at you - okay all the c4 you know
with quality amulets okay I'm okay I'm
fine
yeah did you smoke some more of that
weed good if you want to that's what you
need no you need to take a little
sandwich no need to hit this other [__]
too Godfather
okay that's what you need you need to
calm though and smoke the whole [__]
thing this time
one hit ain't gonna do none for nobody
you gotta [__] hit this ring I can
owe you $20 right hey what's that step
jack
this is the Godfather this is a [__]
the director of the jungles what was
that other one we smoked 2014 walk
carried from for any Alicia's [__] 20
for both of them with some [__]
perennial knocking [__] out 24b
yeah it's so funny because I would never
bounce
I'd still be wearing white cotton
underwear it me undies didn't come into
my life I really wouldn't I didn't even
know underwear like me and these existed
I didn't know underwear like me and
these would be comfortable I mean don't
get me wrong I've seen other types of
briefs but they weren't from me I'm an
old school boxer and an old school
[__] cotton widely tiny widely typing
I don't even like black on the west I
see black on the words and the guy
[__] hide the sudden you got crabs
you don't want to show me your blood
pins and [__] some may write [__]
ah so now guess what I Firefly commando
maybe 6040 but if I got on the world
I got on me on these for two reasons one
comfort and the second reason how moist
and dry dry it keeps me you know why cuz
I'm old dog picture world will putting
on a new pair underwear isn't just fresh
you're stepping into a better day think
about that when you get up in the
morning put your underwear on you know
it's gonna be a great [__] day think
about it underwear is the first thing
you put on the last thing you take off
why would you settle for anything less
than the best feeling underwear on the
planet why me undies is what you're
looking for
it focuses solely on producing the most
comfortable on the way you've ever
experienced period my friends and me
undies send me a while back and now I
can't imagine wearing anything
like I said it makes each day much
better especially when I go jiu-jitsu I
wear those things controls my nuts and
keeps me very dry down there for the
price of two cocktails we on these will
deliver your new favorite pair underwear
right to your doorstep better day
guarantee try them on and if you're not
the most comfortable best feeling undies
you ever had don't refund you and let
you keep the pair for free that's how
confident they are that's real confident
that you're going to like their product
including the prices of sweet touch of
motor oil a special fabric made with the
best-in-class raw materials that are
scientifically proven to be three times
softer than cotton I'm telling you these
uber cozy undies of sold exclusively on
the me on these website where you enjoy
free standard shipping in the US and
Canada for a limited time
this is what I'm going to do everyone in
my audience gets 20% off their first
order but you got to go to our special
URL me undies dot-com slash Joey again
me undies dot-com / Joey 20 percent off
your first order
listen it's Valentine's Day take the
stick out of your ass all right go to me
on these calm right now and get 20% off
your first order with the me on these
better day guarantee you got nothing to
lose so don't wait any longer go to me
on these calm right now / Joey for 20%
off your first daughter
listen go for the two pair it's get a
pair for you and one for Mama the red
one with the hearts you're gonna love
them that's me undies dot-com / Joey
number 2 Lee last week you and I had a
conversation you called me up I think it
was the night you ate the chocolate the
fake chocolate and you were talking
online I faked out what Paul was talking
with fake job did you smoke that pipe
Billy not yet I was trying to oh no no
no hit that [__] meal
this is what a little bit I just talked
to smoke and he leaves it there
yeah hate that thing that's nothing come
on let's go hey the half of fruit it's
gonna calm you down take a good [__]
home you okay right there leave it on
there no no no no no good come on look
look at me I can deal with you see this
no give me the [__] pipe cuz I'm
gonna hit you in the head with it cuz
you aggravate me on purpose
haha like this straight lifts straight
thing and light it don't let it like
this like a candle there you go
now leave it there for a second a little
closer
tilt it took the two o'clock there you
go you say I got a deal no no no no no
no leave the pipe on the [__] fire
you do you see this baby hits do you see
what he's doing to me maybe it's just
embarrassing me you're from the church
huh you want I'm just I have never
smoked with this pipe before just ah ha
ha ha ha ha ha you've been smoking with
that pipe for the last week anyway paula
was cooking what last week oh my god the
West African peanut chicken it was
delicious it was it it's I love peanut
sauce and it was it was really good
we made some jacking with jasmine rice
came with it it was delicious it was it
was it was the best blue pan that we've
had I loved it
I'm gonna make it again working with
jasmine right I think so but I can't it
would work with anything I think would
work with beef I think it would work
with chicken and obviously work with
chicken could probably maybe work with
fish who knows but it was just it was
really good it was a good egg yeah it
took Paul like 45 minutes don't make the
whole thing for less than $10 per person
per meal blue apron will deliver
seasonal recipes along with proportion
ingredients to make your delicious
home-cooked meals choose from a variety
of new recipes each week or let brew a
blue aprons culinary team surprising
recipes are not repeated within a year
so you'll never get bored
customize your recipe each week based on
your preferences blue apron is several
delivery options you can choose what
fits your needs and there's no weekly
commitment so you only get the
deliveries that you want them each meal
comes with a step-by-step easy to follow
a recipe card proportional ingredients
that can be prepared and 40 minutes or
less blue aprons freshness guaranteed
promises that every ingredient in your
delivery arrives ready to cook or
they'll make it right check out this
week's menu right look what they got
this week this is the week to be
employed with cheddar cheese burger was
smoked with sauteed onions and that's a
two-family deal that's the two people
deal like Walla would get with him spice
chicken chili and bake can alone if
you're in the family plan chicken
Milanese with lemon potato salad roasted
pork with apple warm that farro salad
and crispy barramundi who the hell knows
how to cook barramundi you you you know
now you can learn and make an affordable
healthy meal at your home do me a favor
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals free gratis with Free
Shipping by going to blue apron Tom's
last Joey again blue apron calm slash
Joey you'll love how good it feels and
tastes to create incredible home-cooked
meals with blue aprons so don't wait
that's blue apron calm slash Joey blue
apron is a better way to cook all right
and listen who's better than you you
oughta telling you get my Valentine's
Day and you can make a nice dinner with
your wife or girlfriend or your live-in
boyfriend whatever how you got going on
over there you can have a nice time for
Valentine's Day what the [__] are we
talking the money I love is love what is
it better than love than cooking with
somebody again I want to thank blue
apron and I want to thank me on these
for sponsoring the podcast these Delray
sorry to get you off on a bad start no
way that was funny yeah right ah I don't
like to see you like that you're a sharp
kid so we have to do this again sometime
hey me together again now what I love
that you came on and you smoke you
volunteered to smoke the death you know
yeah we don't [__] around with raw
materials here everything we bring into
this studio is 100% you're gonna get
killed
I had to take the ride with you guys
yeah this is how [__] we don't play
in here when I go to the weed store they
know there's a girl they got yeah
there's a professional last three
batches she's given me she told me this
is what you want yeah that stuff is
killer man a little dirty white chick
with freckles yeah they know their
reefer Neff I'm the Midwest I know they
refine us out not these little [__]
Hollywood Valley girls they just look
good and they saw you what you know I'll
say your junk now I'm that blue purple
[__] these little dirty white chicks in
the Midwest I love dirty feet yeah she
had yoga pants on she's all warped and
[__] haha but she knows how to smoke a
week so that's all I can't but Dad talk
about that [__] yeah Lee you survived
you're like the Tom Brady a podcast you
know that no I'm not
who's better than you nobody wins nobody
and I broke your balls for ten twenty
days about that acid for three weeks
I've been tormenting them it's at the
house boiler mm-hmm and I got another
batch in this batch we got about two
months acid uh-huh yeah we wanted to
acid training look illegal depressed oh
I'm under pressure I like it it's just
it's a big it's a big process what
process what do you mean why do you go
home to it you have a milkshake your bed
we do it again tomorrow I would dad
strain I'm gonna I'm gonna see bed yeah
before Wednesday nah you'll be asleep
dependent listen though you said banner
still read I'm gonna leave you with that
whole campaign always yeah when I come
back here tomorrow that better be all
gun that's gonna be you till 6:00 in the
morning
token token when you leave here you go
to the normal diamond you get two eggs
bacon some toast you go home nice with
your belly folk and you call it a night
yeah that's how professional nice that's
how you do it
don't go home and cook don't go home and
talk to nobody want to talk to nobody
you're not gonna talk to nobody another
talk about you're gonna get you two eggs
down in the corner the weight just wants
to talk to you talk to
two minutes after that you walk in the
house about 6:30 and she's getting up
you don't know that we're worried I
don't know yeah I bumped into some
Martians they made me think something ha
ha ha
nobody knows nothing you think I'm a
time I whine none my wife saw the sugar
cubes
she is the acid she thought what do I
give a [__] right or wrong
yep as long as I'm sayin as long as they
don't see it it didn't happen yeah they
don't see it
it didn't [__] happen unless you bring
a clamor or take a picture tweet it like
a half a [__] yeah you'll be [__]
around to my clamorous
I love you [__] see you
Wednesday night 8 o'clock same bat-time
same bat-channel don't forget to support
my brother Dean Delray February 18th
in Denver what's name of the theater su
Teatro can they go to your website to
get tickets yeah yep and there's a link
a code candles lit get you a discount
discount for you see you nice girl have
a great time I love you [__] see
you Wednesday night 8 p.m. same bat-time
same bat-channel
- we're doing we did - tonight we're due
for doses Wednesday oh my god I love you
guys stay calm
[Music]
you